or Ukraine's top military command says
there is heavy fighting in front line
hot spots and Keith says more than two
dozen battles took place in the past 24
hours around the Eastern town of bakmuts
and further south that's after Ukraine
said it retook three villages in the
west of the Donetsk region Moscow has
not commented on those Villages but said
that it repelled attacks elsewhere in
the East we'll get reaction from Russia
in a moment with yoya chapovalova in
Moscow but first let's bring in Jonah ho
joining us from the Ukrainian capital Q
so Jonah tell us more about what we're
hearing about the fighting near the
front lines
lots of reports coming in in the last 24
hours or so and particularly even in the
last hour or two indicating what we
described as small but incremental
progress for Ukrainian forces in these
early days of their counter-offensive at
various points along uh the front line
uh focusing it seems on Southern Donetsk
region in the east on or near the border
of zaparisia region which of course
takes the front line further to the
southeast and down all the way to the
Sea of azov uh military command talking
about some 25 separate battles that have
taken place particularly in the south of
Donis region but also including around
the city of bakmud captured by the
Russians of course just last month and
Russian sources appear to be confirming
as well that they've sustained attacks
to the South and Northern flanks of that
city of bakmut and social media full of
stories of course tweets and retweets
showing Ukrainian soldiers holding up
the Ukrainian flag in a number of these
small Villages that the command says
have been liberated places like uh
makarifka and in the last hour or two as
I said a place called storogi these are
not household names of course many
ukrainians probably will never have
heard of these small villages but they
do represent as I say small steps in the
counter-offensive retaking even small
pieces of land and that is something of
course that the ukrainians want to make
known and they want to make known as
well the impression that Russia is very
much on the back foot as a result of all
of this Hana Malia the deputy defense
minister in her Daily Briefing
suggesting that Russia was moving some
of its most capable combat forces from
Elsewhere on the front line towards
these focal points in Donetsk region and
zapore Asia region and indeed there are
reports from the ukrainians that the
Russians in an attempt to slow Ukrainian
advances have blown up a dam on
democriale river we can't independently
very verify that it is apparently a
small dam but that of course comes just
a week or so now after Russia is accused
of blowing up the much larger kakovka
Dam in Herson region causing what some
experts have described as ecoside okay
thank you that's Jonah Hall reporting
for us from Kiev let's now bring in uh
journalist
so as as always in war there are claims
in counter claims tell us what we're
hearing from the Russian side
um at the moment there is no official
information regarding Russia's activity
in the front line but Russia continues
fighting obviously earlier there were
reports about heavy fighting in the
zaparosia direction the Russian side
repelled all the Ukrainian attacks
according to the sources here now
military bloggers discuss situation in
the southern donesk front the ukrainians
tried to find weak spots in Russia's
defenses there and some defense lines
have been reportedly broken so Russian
servicemen allegedly withdrew to more
suitable for them positions due to the
threat of being surrounded on Monday
morning some telegram channels basically
reported heavy fighting in the area also
the Russian defense Ministry reported
that 94 Russian military men were
released from the Ukrainian captivity
after
well some negotiations loan negotiations
I should say and all of those released
soldiers will be taken to medical
facilities for treatment and
Rehabilitation so we're waiting for more
information to come here
okay thank you so much
giving us that update from Moscow
well Ukrainian officials are saying that
three people have been killed and 10
injured after Russian forces shelled a
boat carrying flood evacuees from the
Russian occupied part of the kherson
region some 4 000 people were rescued
from the flood zone an attack on the
Nova kakovka Dam last week flooded
entire Villages and it left tens of
thousands without power and clean water
Key Van Moscow accused each other of
destroying that Dam but for people
living in Herson the flooding has only
added to their suffering
today we probably don't have a single
family that hasn't faced the
consequences of War whether it's death
destruction or fear
people have become different children
have become noticeably different they
become more grown up